good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight people haven't been
traveling much they've been stuck at
home but if you had a chance to visit
new york city recently
if you have you know the truth it's
awful
awful in a very recognizable way new
york today looks a lot like new york in
the 1970s but without studio 54.
the city has once again become dirty
chaotic and dangerous the parks and
train stations look like refugee camps
for mentally ill drug users
just as in the 1970s a lot of people who
live in new york are fleeing
in fact maybe you're one of them maybe
you're watching this show
right now maskless from your patio in
fort lauderdale or naples glass of wine
in hand and thinking to yourself
why should i care about what happens in
new york
i voted with my feet i'd get out of that
place let it rot
and honestly that's a fair point but
consider another perspective
new york is the biggest city in the
united states more than 8 million people
live there including americans
what happens in new york affects all of
us in the end we're going to have to pay
for the damage anyway
so we might as well root for the best
outcome there
tonight believe it or not something good
might be happening in new york city in
fact something good
is happening there bill de blasio is
heading for retirement
we know that for sure the single worst
mayor in the history of representative
government has reached the end of his
second disastrous term the long
municipal nightmare
is over de blasio's leaving so the
question is
who replaces him until recently we
assumed that would be andrew yang the
guy who just the other day was running
for president we talked to him as he ran
and we found that unlike
a lot of 2020 democrats beta o'rourke
looking at you andrew yang is not stupid
in fact he's legitimately smart
at times he's been insightful and
willing to talk about interesting ideas
in public
unfortunately in the end the weight of
andrew yang's life credentials exeter
brown columbia law school
pulled him back to the poisonous culture
that produced him in the first place
and he embraced probably inevitably the
dumbest kind of identity politics
so at this point the only real
difference between andrew yang and the
next unhappy lady browsing the aisles at
whole foods in a mask
is that andrew yang is slightly more
articulate and that's sad
another one bites the dust but still we
assumed that andrew yang would win the
democratic primary in new york because
it's the democratic primary in new york
but we were wrong
he may not win it turns out new york is
changing
all that urban decay appears to have
awakened voters to
actual issues according to a new poll
andrew yang is
losing as of today to a guy called eric
adams he's the brooklyn
borough president controversial for many
years
in a lot of ways eric adams is a
conventional big city democrat he's into
identity politics too
the difference is that eric adams is
eccentric enough to say what he really
thinks once in a while for example
in a speech last year adams launched
into an attack on the smug fussy
liberals who have flooded into new york
over the past three decades
he addressed an audience of people who
have to live with them
and you can sympathize quote you were
here before starbucks
you were here before others came and
decided they wanted to be part of this
city
folks are not only hijacking your
apartments and displacing your living
arrangements
they displace your conversations and say
the things that are important to you
are no longer important so what exactly
was eric adams talking about
what are the important things that smug
fussy liberals don't want you to talk
about
what crime and disorder mostly and those
matter
once you're afraid of getting shot to
death while walking to the store once
you can't use the park across the street
because vagrants are living there
nothing else really matters no matter
what color you are crime and disorder
define your life
and whatever else he is eric adams is
bright enough to understand that
he spent 20 years as a cop in new york
here's his announcement for mayor
we're facing a crisis unlike anything
we've ever seen before
businesses are closing crime is rising
homelessness is soaring and our families
are struggling
we can't have an education system that
fails to put our children on a pathway
of success
and leaves them at a dead end of crime
and hopelessness
so businesses are closing crime is
rising
homelessness is soaring adam said that
out loud and by itself that is a
victory in the context of new york
politics a victory of reality over
delusion
for years as there has been a rigid code
among those smug fussy liberals in new
york city
that you're not allowed to notice as
things fall apart
and to the extent that you do notice
you're supposed to think it's charming
or diverse or somehow related to equity
more drug ods in penn station
how vibrant but eric adams doesn't think
that way at all he thinks all of that is
awful
and here's his solution don't put up
with that crap
bring back order crack down make new
york city
safe again everything depends on it and
he's right
watch it doesn't make any consolation
if a police officer shoots someone
illegally
or if some a gang banger in blue jeans
no matter what community i am in
people want their families to be safe
and that resonates
with everyday new yorkers and i know my
message will resonate with them
if we're not safe in this city companies
are not coming to new york
our multi-billion dollars tourism
industry
is not going to return if tourists are
shot
at grand central station and so the
first order of business is to get
violence under control
well yeah the first order of business is
to get violence
under control you would think that would
be the top priority of every new york
city politician
why have a mayor otherwise but it's not
their top priority it's not even close
the current mayor spends half his life
opining on global warming
even as he pollutes the atmosphere with
his weed smoke
eric adams is actually serious about
fighting crime house years he said if he
becomes mayor
he plans to carry his own gun can you
imagine bill de blasio doing that he
would shoot himself by accident
so as mayor would you carry a firearm on
you even with the security detail
yes i will number one and number two i
won't have a security detail
if the city is safe the mayor shouldn't
have a security detail with him he
should be walking the street by himself
number three the hypocrisy of those who
are city-wide officials
who said that you shouldn't have guns in
church those guys that walk in with them
they got guns so
you can tell how true something is by
how
the usual hysterics respond to it in
this case they were totally horrified
display bravery defend yourself show
evidence of a higher than average
testosterone level how could you
eric adams later suggested he might have
been joking
but as you just saw he wasn't joking he
obviously meant that
and normal voters appreciated it why
wouldn't they
meanwhile once promising andrew yang has
descended deeper into the
self-discrediting absurdity of modern
identity politics
something that it turns out most voters
actually don't like who knew
at a form the other day yang was asked
about violence against asian americans
now every single human being in new york
city understands where that violence
comes from
but of course yang did not say that his
solution
give more taxpayer money to racial
affinity groups aligned with the
democratic party
that'll make asian grandmothers safe
except it won't make asian grandmothers
or anyone
else safe we know because we tried it it
doesn't work
all that does work is enforcing the law
and most people know that yet enforcing
the law
is the one thing that andrew yang
opposes
yang is called for taking more money
from the nypd budget and giving it to
mental health services
whatever that means then in a radio
interview yang suggested that defunding
the police by a billion dollars
which they've done might not be enough
you know they um
they did shift a billion dollars from
the nypd
you know to to to to other things but
would you do more than that would you do
more than a billion
i think that's what we need to be
looking at the reality is if you're
going to look at the city budget the
nypd
is the most likely place to look because
we're just spending a lot of money
on the nypd the sad thing is
people like andrew yang exeter brown
columbia
are such craven butt kissers they don't
understand the advantage in telling the
truth if he'd said the radio host are
you joking
defund the police that's insane the
radio host probably would have agreed
with him but that's not what yang did he
tried to suck up and he humiliated
himself and then he went on from there
yang has demanded that the police learn
martial arts
purple belt at minimum so they won't
have to use their weapons just
well-placed karate chops
yang is also called for changing the
uniforms and titles in police
departments across the country quote
i might rename them guardians he wrote
and adopt a different color scheme
oh a different color scheme you got to
wonder is there still a constituency for
ideas
this stupid and the answer is of course
grad school liberals love this stuff
fawning over criminals makes them feel
good about themselves
and then when things disintegrate as of
course they will the grad school
liberals just leave
they literally head for the hills telly
ride aspen beaver creek
anywhere without the quote crime problem
and a lot of them are doing that now
the liberals who still remain in new
york don't have much use for eric adams
weirdly
he's the one black candidate they don't
like
you get the feeling he doesn't like them
back he definitely doesn't believe them
when they talk
here's eric adams on the radio in july
sympathizing with
of all people donald trump
we're in a period of sexy headlines
truth be damn man i'm not like nobody
cares about truth anymore
man this is a this is an instagram
twitter
universe where people say listen we're
sexy
with cells that's what it is the same
thing they accuse donald trump of
man that far far far left please man
we know moderate thinking communication
real facts don't even matter in this
universe we're in right now
could it be that things have fallen
apart to such an extent in new york that
they've gotten
so crazy that someone like eric adams
who you would have laughed off the stage
18 months ago as crazy himself actually
is the sanest guy running and maybe the
one person who can save the city from
itself
we don't know but it wouldn't be the
weirdest thing that's happened this year
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it
anywhere else